Avatar came with the best commander
centric legend I've seen in a long time.
Commander ccentric is a way of building
EDH decks that leans entirely on the
commander. It often features really
linear and consistent play patterns.
Practice one punch a thousand times kind
of deal. And our main character today is
Ang at the crossroads and the flip side
a destined savior. Now this card suffers
from the same problem many other
universes beyond commanders do. The
design is way too complicated. is like a
freaking book and the abilities don't
really have much synergy with each
other. So, as usual, we just completely
ignore the weaker abilities and focus on
the text that matters. And this is a
sweet paragraph of rules text. I'm
surprised that this never existed on
another card in the past. But building
around this will allow us to keep the
play pattern simple and linear, but have
completely random outcomes in different
games. We are technically only playing
with our commander but winning with a
massive toolbox of creatures. Hello,
this is Jyn with Next Level Commander.
If you're interested in the commander
centric play styles and other uniquely
powerful decks, please subscribe and let
me know if you have commanders that can
work well with this philosophy. So, the
game plan here is simple. We cast Ang
and blink. That's pretty much all we do
until we reach the oppase and that's
when we can close out games pretty
quickly. More on that later. Now, let's
quickly go over our toolbox of mystery.
No one knows if we are coming up with
the wrench or the screwdriver next, but
they're all useful. Starting with ramp,
we have nine pieces. One of the biggest
obstacles here is an cast costing five
mana. And ideally, when casting him, we
want some mana up to blink at least once
for protection. Unlike many other
commandercentric decks though, we do
have action early and don't mind waiting
till turn six or seven to cast our
commander. I mean, the deck is filled
with lowc cost utility creatures. Uh,
but yeah, we still want our commander
out as soon as it's safe. Next up,
answers. Ben is the color combination
that can answer literally anything. So,
we have a decent variety. Creatures,
non-creatures, graveyard, and even
spells. We also have a few clones. These
are probably some of the best cards to
blink. The deck is pretty light on win
conditions, so we'll definitely be
feasting on our opponents crater hooves
and Avengers. The draw choices here are
quite unusual. Riverwise Augur is great
because it's like a brainstorm that can
set up our next flip. Mo Drifter is five
mana, so we have the equivalent dream
entrancer. Just stun angs.
Generous patron is another personal
favorite, drawing two on ETB on most
board states. And finally, recursion. In
the early game, these are most likely
returning a blink spell for another
role. But later on when we have some
doubling shenanigans, these turn into
win conditions that can swarm our
opponents with value. For blink spells,
we are going heavy with 21. Starting
with some of the typical choices, we do
want a few slow blink options to protect
Ang from board wipes. And these mass
blink effects are straight up value town
when we have a decent board. Restoration
angel is a four drop, so it just resets
Ang while adding a free three for flyer
to the board. That's the floor. And
again with any doubling effect we are
going to value town. Thasa gives us an
indestructible blink outlet every turn
while Emo the bless is the best mana
sync in the mid to late game. Deck seems
simple enough. Blink ang to get random
creatures. Blink him again for another
seems fair but fair is not what we're
looking to do here. At least not in the
late game. Enter the enablers. Starfield
vocalist and roaming throne are both
anable. Anable. Yeah.
Not sure about this one. but they will
double up the ETB triggers. With roaming
throne, we choose humans because we have
like 10 of those in the deck. Preston is
another doubler that I've always wanted
to find a deck for and is perfect here.
And for some card advantage, arch mage
ameritus gives Kentrip to all our blink
spells while Mavinda allows us to use
them twice. Displacer kitten needs no
introduction is game changer levels of
gamechanging in this deck. And most
importantly, remember when I teased the
oppase earlier? Yeah, this is where we
bulldoze the table by first yelling,
"Yep, yep,
>> yep, yep."
>> And drop one of these creatures, led by
Apa, of course. Being able to crash in
and allow us to reuse all the ETB
effects for two mana is strong. But
actually, AA is the weakest of the
bunch. Lumber Battleman, for example,
will straight up exile all our creatures
and trigger all the ETBs at once when it
leaves. So, yeah, the moment one of
these beasts come in, we are no longer
blinking our commander. We are blinking
these and going nuclear.
Abdo Adrien as well. Glorious protector
is glorious because it can be found with
Ang. But even at five mana, these
effects are well worth hard casting for
how quickly they will take over games.
Oh, and Urion, very similar effect. For
non-creatures, we have Cream of the
Crop. Every angrier sets us up for the
next one perfectly. And Squack is
perfect for this deck as well. To round
out the non-land cards, we have a few
tutors to the top of the deck, of
course, to get out key enablers. And
Court of Calling is pretty much get any
creature from the deck for close to free
considering the board state will usually
have. And that wraps up the non lens.
The land base here is actually really
interesting. I know I said we are
ignoring the backside, but it does have
some sweet synergy with lands. And it
doesn't cost much to adjust the land
base. And by that I mean the opportunity
costing deck building, not in terms of
price because holy crap, earthbending is
ridiculous with fetch lens. We are
probably flipping our commander quite
often anyways. I mean, it's not going to
save flipped because blinks, but
entering combat with Ang destined savior
won't be uncommon. And when we do, the
fetchlands become free rampant growth.
And all these sacrifice effects will net
us one extra land. Now, when we get to
Earthbend, I'd say four times out of
five, it will be put onto a fetchland.
So, we don't need to go nuts with these
sacrifice effects. Just one for draw,
one for life gain, and one reusable
emergence. So, that that's pretty fun.
And of course, a strip mine. Outside of
the self-sacrifice lens, ETB effects
like Mosport Bridge can also be reused.
I mean, it's not sacrificing itself, but
it will probably die to natural causes
like wrath of God or some showdown, and
you can always include it with your mass
blink turns. Another angle to approach
this is the indestructible lens. Getting
a few indestructible blockers can come
in handy, and it's a fun perk that very
few commanders can provide. And that's
the deck. The play pattern is fairly
simple and straightforward. Play some
early creatures to interact and when the
time comes, drop ang and blink away.
Blink in response to removal, blink in
response to opponent shenanigans, blink
at the end of turn or blink just because
you want to. And eventually we enter the
apuff phase. We overwhelm with value and
yip yip our way into the sunset. The
deck is not too explosive because of the
expensive commander, but definitely
resilient. Once N is on the field,
there's really not much your opponents
can do about it. The deck is really easy
to play. For a good chunk of the game,
you're just doing one action over and
over. Maybe once in a while you choose a
target or two, but when you start
doubling up and mass blinking, it might
get a bit more complicated, but I'm sure
your table will help you figure out
things just to get it over with. And the
deck is mid-budget. It can get expensive
if you want to maximize its potential,
and some of the most interesting
enablers are costly. But again, a budget
version can easily perform at around 80%
power for maybe a quarter of the price.
And finally, this deck sits snugly in
bracket three. We only have two game
changers in the list. If you're looking
to add another seedorn muse might be
pretty strong here. And of course, you
can't go wrong with Gais Cradle. And
there you have it. Ang with the all-in
commander ccentric deck building. And as
usual, the list is in the descriptions.
If you enjoy this deck, please like and
subscribe. There's a bunch more down the
pipeline. For example, I'm currently
looking at a control deck with Ozai. Big
mana, lots of interesting synergies. So
yeah, this is Jyn with Next Level
Commander, and I will see you in the
next video.